[Musique]
selon elle ses tisanes oui c'est ism
quel drôle de nom pour un rappeur local
enfants il a été marqué par le
chef-d'oeuvre orson welles
mais notre citizen kane et bien portois
l'open avec l'introduction de ce nouveau
titre
la voiture on sait c'est une pole de
jesse
de toute fa ti fait référence au roi du
piton des neiges à l'époque des maraudes
pour sa nouvelle production citizen le
magicien des mots s'est baladé dans le
corps les habitants de la vessie dr
anatole-france présent dans le nouvel
album dans le jargon dino nouvel ep
comcom l'auberson quand il est venu dans
la cour on n'écoute plus à faire tout le
monde sait ici parce que non tant que
bonne parole que la touche à nos 50 du
coût mais il me plaît à nous pour nous
tous que l'ebit est en dedans dans le
bon sens
médiatiser cette affaire c'est que le
truc que l'ags est convaincu mana de
lhasa nous filmer ce début la chanson
lui dis ça devient du jeu tu crois ça
veut dire de la tête du coc et c'est là
qu'elle m'a dit que le collectif
s'appelait jean rédélé la de l'écurie
big up à ses amis de la cité des chocas
pour des apparitions furtives dans le
clip
un rappeur qui n'a pas la grosse tête il
a pourtant bossé avec les grands comme
bnl c'est un fausse pour moi parce que
tous ces thèmes très traditionnelle et y
empêche pas moins les seuils mêlant
chèque
on a fait du jeu jusqu'à parce qu'il est
quand même des années 90 mais les années
2000 tous il m'a proposé de jouer comme
un esclavage en fait qui court qui était
un jeune blessé
et voilà et franchement j'y viendrai le
nouvel ep de citizen kane fait déjà
sensation sur les plateforme deezer
spotify et itunes
selon la formule consacrée un rappeur
qui nous réserve encore des surprises
pourquoi pas à l'international
[Musique]